warning Russia before I come to that do
remember this is not the first time that
emphasis is facing visa issues in the
u.s. let me start with this case for IT
workers based in the u.s. in their
lawsuit which was filed in 2013 who have
said that they were Caucasians of
American national origin had alleged
that they were discriminated against
because they were not South Asian Indian
Bangladeshi or Nepalese and that's the
update on that case really is that a
judge in a district court in the u.s.
yesterday rejected a plea by emphasis to
dismiss the discrimination lawsuit
dealing a blow to the company ruling on
the case the judge has said that the
plaintiffs class allegations are
impossible in the US the court would not
dismiss them before permitting any
discovery in that case in a response to
Bloomberg TV India the company has said
it does not comment on ongoing
litigation this ruling expected to take
emphasis to another phase of legal
battle in the u.s. from where derives
almost 60% of its overall revenues and
is a particularly sensitive subject for
the IT major a bit of a backstory here
emphasis had to pay nearly thirty four
million dollars for the settlement of a
civil case in the US over allegations
that it misused its visa quota after
former employer employee I beg your
pardon and whistle blows Jack Palma
filed a suit alleging that he was
targeted after he brought up the issue
of misuse of short-term business visas
before in phasis while the petition was
dismissed by a district court in August
2012 emphasis was asked by the US
authorities to retain an independent
third-party auditor at this expense to
review its entire visa compliance issue
until 2015 so a bloke at least
sentimentally for emphasis come again